[Música]
como les anunciamos en esta emisión
especial es de directo a América
estaremos analizando los 20 años de la
invasión de Irak con información de
nuestros cronistas intervenciones de
nuestra enviada especial y también en
análisis de nuestros invitados vamos a
abrir con la revista de prensa de Marta
Moya Marta Un saludo para usted Buenos
días Ángela y hoy dedicamos nuestra
revista de prensa a este gran tema de
los 20 años de la invasiones de Irak por
parte de la coalición de voluntarios que
estaba liderada por Estados Unidos y por
Reino Unido 20 años que hoy todavía nos
dejan unos titulares con grandes
interrogantes sí Ángela vamos a hacer un
poco de repaso por esos titulares y esas
todavía incongruencias e interrogantes
que nos deja esta guerra todo empezó o
todo se intensificó Mejor dicho después
de los atentados del 11s en Nueva York
Entonces cuando se declara la guerra
contra el terrorismo por parte de la
Administración Bush empieza esa presión
para que
se desarmara de esas presuntas armas de
destrucción masiva empieza Pues a
intensificarse esa tensión y al final el
18 de marzo
George Bush lanza un ultimátum a Sadam
hussein que le dice que tiene que
abandonar Irak o entonces iniciará la
guerra escuchemos
y sus hijos deben abandonar Irak en 48
horas si se oponen terminará en un
conflicto armado que empezará cuando
nosotros elijamos para su seguridad
todas las personas foráneas y locales
Incluyendo a periodistas e inspectores
deben irse de Irak inmediatamente
la prensa estadounidense concretamente
la televisión CVS reportaba así los
primeros minutos después de ese
ultimátum porque Sadam evidentemente no
salió del país escuchemos Cómo fue ese
inicio
desde los estudios centrales de la CVS
en Nueva York Aquí está Dance han pasado
solo alrededor de 90 minutos desde que
el ultimátum del presidente Bush para
que Sadam hussein abandonara Irak los
barcos y aviones de guerra
estadounidenses ya han lanzado la
primera salva de su operación libertad
iraquí el ataque se produjo con ráfagas
de misiles de crucero y bombarderos
antibunkers para acabar con el escondite
que se cree que alberga a los altos
dirigentes del régimen
iraquín
y ahora vamos a destacar las palabras de
Tony Blair entonces Primer Ministro de
Reino Unido que probablemente se
convirtió en el Aliado más fiel de
George Bush en esta en este lanzamiento
de la invasión airak escuchemos
en la noche del martes y la orden para
que las tropas británicas tomen partido
en la acción militar en Irak los hombres
y mujeres de nuestro ejército tienen el
compromiso por tierra y por aire para
eliminar a Sadam husein del Poder y
desarmar Irak de sus armas de
destrucción masiva traction vamos ahora
a repasar algunas de las portadas de la
prensa estadounidense de aquel 20 de
marzo de 2003 Pues si Ángela vamos a
hacer un poco de retrospectiva y mirada
hacia atrás de los titulares que nos
dejaban las principales portadas de la
prensa estadounidense hemos destacado
cinco Aunque por supuesto todos los
medios habrían Entonces igual empezamos
con el New York Times que entonces
titulaba Bush ordena empezar la guerra
en Irak los misiles Aparentemente no
alcanzan a hussein vemos esa foto
icónica de los primeros bombardeos
alcanzando en esas primeras horas de la
mañana a la capital Bagdad el 20 de
marzo de 2003 el presidente advierte
sostenido de la de la operación en una
desafiante respuesta al régimen
destacamos también la portada del
Filadelfia en quire que titulaba golpe a
Bagdad ataques con bombas dirigidas a
hussein Y destacaba esa cita de George
Bush una vez ya da por iniciada la
guerra que decía no aceptaremos otro
resultado que no sea la victoria también
destacamos la portada del Washington
post de ese 20 de marzo de 2003 que
titulaba entonces Estados Unidos abre su
guerra con ataques en Bagdad dirigidos a
hussein el líder iraquí se muestra
desafiante en un mensaje a la nación
televisado después del ataque justain
decía Entonces que se tenían que
desenfundar los cuchillos contra el
enemigo explosiones rasgan la
tranquilidad de la mañana eso decía el
Washington post El San Francisco crónico
El titulaba entonces Bueno una palabra
que lo Define todo que es la palabra
guerra misiles y bombas en Bagdad
Estados Unidos apunta a la cúpula iraquí
la estrategia del gobierno pasa por
evitar una batalla que haya calle porque
se esperaban esos ataques directamente
direccionados a los líderes del régimen
iraquí y por finalizar destacamos la
portada del Boston globe que titulaba
entonces empieza la guerra de Irak
Estados Unidos dispara en sitios
estratégicos el objetivo inicial está
claro el capítulo final incierto bueno
diferentes medios de prensa como usted
nos está mostrando registraron el inicio
de la invasión pasó en occidente y pasó
en más medios locales si Ángela hemos
destacado tres portadas de quizá los
aliados principales de Estados Unidos en
esta guerra que fueron Reino Unido y
España destacamos la portada del
Guardian de ese 20 de marzo de 2003 que
decía ir a lanzados los primeros
disparos
170.000 tropas estadounidenses y
británicas están listas y en esa portada
también destacaba que los refugios de
Bagdad son un Santuario para los muertos
no un lugar seguro la portada del país
de España titulaba ese 20 de marzo
Estados Unidos ataca Irak misiles de
crucero scan sobre Bagdad a las 3:35 de
la mañana y Bush asegura que intentará
evitar la muerte de civiles
pesein había situado instalaciones
militares en zonas civiles algo que
bueno pues no fue así porque al final
fueron más de 300.000 los muertos y
destacamos finalmente la portada del
Daily mirror que decía destrucción
masiva y no se refería a las armas sino
a esos primeros ataques estadounidenses
en bata Y eso de los muertos Marta es
muy cuestionable porque dependiendo de
la Fuente que usted revise van desde los
100.000 hasta los 500.000 y no Por
supuesto que no se cumplió esa promesa y
hoy lo sigue pagando el país
sin embargo en medio de todo este
conflicto naciones como Francia o como
Alemania decidieron mantenerse al margen
de otros aliados y dijeron No a la
guerra si Ángela destacamos un artículo
del Guardián un encuentro entre el
entonces presidente francés Jack sheerak
y el canciller Alemán roder que se
reunieron el 22 de marzo justo dos días
después de que empezara la invasión Y
ambos se posicionarán claramente en
contra de la guerra decían que el
consejo de seguridad de Naciones Unidas
tenía que tener más tiempo para evaluar
si efectivamente había o no armas de
destrucción masiva desde Francia shirak
decía que mientras otros socios apoyaban
a Irak O sea a Estados Unidos como Reino
Unido o España ellos decían que la
guerra era la prueba del fracaso y la
peor de las soluciones y que se debe
hacer todo para evitarla eso decía
shirak y por la parte de Alemania decían
que no esperaban de Alemania apoyar una
resolución que legitimara la guerra los
medios latinoamericanos también Hicieron
su propio reporte después del inicio de
la guerra si Ángela y hemos destacado
también cinco portadas porque América
Latina También estuvo reportando ese
inicio invasión empezamos con un medio
brasileño con o globo que titulaba
Bagdad bombardeada Bush dice que la
guerra puede ser larga hemos destacado
también El Universal de México que
titulaba entonces Irak bajo fuego falla
el primer ataque de Bush porque entonces
en ese primer ataque no se mató a Sadam
hussein y dice también que hussein
aparece y convoca al mundo árabe a la
yihad en ese mensaje para
levantarse contra los enemigos el
colombiano titulaba ese 20 de marzo de
2003 conmoción y pavor que es como se
denominó a la operación de esos primeros
días en Bagdad los misiles alcanzaron
los palacios de hussein y opiniones en
el mundo divididas y crecían las
protestas esto lo señalaba el colombiano
hoy de República Dominicana titulada
empieza la invasión tras los iniciales
ataques aéreos las fuerzas terrestres
entran en Irak y para finalizar
destacamos el de la mañana que decía
Bagdad arde vamos a dejar ahora las
portadas y pasamos a la actualidad del
New York Times publica un artículo este
lunes sobre los interrogantes que
todavía nos deja esta guerra que al
final nunca tuvo una justificación Así
es Ángela y dice el New York Times que
al final los debates actuales pasan por
saber quién sabía que cuándo y qué es lo
que más importaba para justificar la
invasión a Irak dice que los debates no
son sobre las muertes estadounidenses
militares que se cuentan por más de
4.000 o las vidas iraquíes que se
acuerdan como decíamos en una horquilla
muy amplia entre 100.000 y 500.000 el
New York Times habla de más de 300.000
ni siquiera el costo militar para
Estados Unidos y económico que fue más
de 800 millones de dólares sin costar
sin contar Perdón Los costos indirectos
ni siquiera las consecuencias de la
guerra sumira Irak en una guerra civil
el ascenso del yihadismo o castigar el
intervencionismo estadouni sino que la
pregunta pasa por porque invadió Estados
Unidos Irán no según un alto funcionario
del departamento de estado Decía ya en
2004 sólo un año después me iré a la
tumba sin saberlo no es que falten
piezas de este rompecabezas sino que hay
que saber qué motivo a los funcionarios
estadounidenses a tomar la decisión de
invadir Esto es lo que dice el New York
Times y al final dice una masa crítica
de altos funcionarios se sentó en la
mesa queriendo derrocar a Sadam hussein
por sus propios motivos y se
convencieron unos a otros para que
creyeran en la justificación
pero todavía hoy no la tenemos Marta
vamos a terminar con un artículo del
medio español El Diario punto es que
refleja como la justificación de la
invasión y la propia guerra pues
estuvieron plagados de errores desde el
inicio Así es Y dice el diario punto es
la justificación de invadir que era
acabar con las armas de destrucción
masiva y la coalición de voluntarios de
los 40 países liderados por Estados
Unidos sólo sirvió para que Bush
disimulara esta guerra ilegal que
carecía de autorización eso dice el
diario.es todo empezó en 2002 cuando la
estimación Nacional de inteligencia
afirmaba que Sadam hussein tenía armas
químicas armas biológicas y estaba
trabajando en su Arsenal nuclear sin
embargo pues Andy marquidis encargado de
trasladarle esa inteligencia al gobierno
Bush entre 2002 y 2004 dice textualmente
tristemente no se equivocamos en la
mayoría ni la justificación de la
invasión ni la vinculación de al-qaeda
con Irak eran opiniones ni cosas que
estaban justificadas para que al final
Estados Unidos y sus aliados invadieran
este país afirmaciones falsas que nunca
pudieron ser probadas gracias a usted
Marte y vamos a continuar hablando sobre
este tema a lo largo de nuestra jornada
de nuestro bloque gracias